hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast friends with brain benefits
the impact of gut microbiota on neuro
development and behavior
I am Brenda Kelly Kim of lab rats and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar
presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning before we start there are a few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers are always welcome - you
can do this by hitting the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window typing in your
comments and questions we'll try to get
to as many as we can and we'll follow up
with you we don't have time today want a
better look you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you can't hear or see this
presentation properly please let us know
by clicking on the support button on the
top right or use the Q&A button we'll
try to make sure we resolve any issues
this is an educational web webinar and
thus offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the seat button located in the
bottom left-hand corner of your webpage
and follow the process to obtain your
credits now let's get right to today's
presenter we are proud to welcome dr.
John crying John crying professor and
chair Department of anatomy and
neuroscience University College Cork
Cork Ireland he received a BS science
and PhD from the national university of
ireland galway ireland was a visiting
fellow at the department psychiatry
University of Melbourne Australia which
was followed by postdoctoral fellowships
at the University of Pennsylvania
Philadelphia and the Scripps Research
Institute La Jolla California he spent
four years at the Novartis Institute for
biomedical research in Basel Switzerland
as a lab head behavioral pharmacology
prior to joining joining University
College Cork in 2005 where he was
appointed a full professor in two
2011 professor cryin has an h-index of
68 having published over 300 peer review
articles he was selected as a highly
cited researcher by Thomas Reuters he
has edited three books he is the senior
editor of new pharmacology and
nutritional neuroscience and an editor
of the british journal of pharmacology
is best known for his work on animal
models of stress-related disorders and
their pharmacological treatment more
recently his team has been instrumental
in demonstrating a role for the gut
microbiome and regulating brain and
behavior I'll now turn it over to dr.
Kryon for his presentation prime classic
good morning everyone
Thank You Brenda for that kind
invitation and it's really an honor to
speak among this great number of people
on the bobrucz symposium and the goal of
this is that you can do things without
leaving your home unfortunately I've
left my home I'm doing it from a hotel
in Germany so I hope it all works out
okay and again I'd like to this is st.
Patrick's Day so I'd like to wish
everyone a happy st. Patrick's Day
wherever you are celebrating in the
world and I'd also like to welcome those
people who are watching this back on
demand and you're very welcome
as well so what I'm going to talk about
is the journey that we've been on in our
lab over the last number of years trying
to really understand how your gust could
influence your brain and and the
implications that that might have for
particularly stress-related psychiatric
disorders and it's really a become a
paradigm shifts in neuroscience to start
thinking about anything below the neck
and so over the next 45 minutes or so I
hope that I can persuade you that there
is a lot of value to trying to
understand this complex interaction and
I work in a medical school and in
inmates and in general
fields of microbiology and neuroscience
rarely talk to each other there have
been some exceptions going back to the
time of syphilis and neurosyphilis and
more recently when we really appreciate
the cognitive sea quality of the HIV
virus and may have in patients that are
surviving but for the most part these
disciplines are quite distinct and even
the discipline of gastroenterology and
neuroscience is another one which is
quite distinct even though we have
what's known as a brain Gus so I want to
take you back I want to take you back to
rural Michigan in the eighteen hundreds
and there you have this US Army surgeon
called William Beaumont and Beaumont was
one of the prototypical clinician
scientists he was very interested in how
the body worked and we knew very little
back then about how the digestive tract
worked and he had a patient called
Alexis st. Martin a Canadian fur trader
who unfortunately got an abdomen wound
caused by a gunshot and Beaumont saved
his life but a fistula emerged opening
in the side and that allowed women to
get really good insight into the
physiology of the digestive tract and he
started performing experiments and
writing about by looking at the rate of
digestion the what was in the digestive
juices etc and so he kept st. Martin as
almost a human guinea pig for many years
with this opening doing these
experiments and he noticed that if st.
Martin became understandably at times
irritable or angry and who's to blame on
that it affected the rate of digestion
that your emotions changed what was
going on in your gut and this was
subsequently taken up by many of the
Great's of modern physiology from Pavlov
to Cannon to to Barnard and even Darwin
has written about it
in this classical text the expressions
of the emotions and man animal so we
have the brain got axes and with the
advent of imaging studies in the 1980s
we began to really realize that this is
this is bi-directional here is a MRI
scan from Emery Myers group at UCLA
showing that this tension of the colon
can cause activation stage in key brain
areas that we know are very important
for regulating emotion such as the
anterior we have is bi-directional brain
good actors and and the concept of mind
body interactions really you know has
been very well appreciated in
complementary medicine fields but in
traditional medicine it has had less of
an impact to date and that it despite
these well delineated modes of
communication including here I'll point
out the vagus nerve because I'll come
back to that a little later and so it's
still seeing this a little bit out there
that we should be studying this brain
good axis in neuroscience and you know
my lab is particularly interested in
stress and how stress affects the brain
and how stressed and particularly
traumatic stress their early life stress
will have long term impact and oh and
you know we're living in a stressful
world and everywhere we go and and so
understanding the mechanism of how
stress is having such impact may help us
to get better treatments where there's a
clear need to have and it's work noting
as pointed by others that stress will
have different impacts depending on when
in the light across the lifespan it
occurs we're quite interested as I
mentioned the stress in the perinatal
period but also stress in adolescents
and and stress in ageing and
understanding what's going on in the
brain
during these key periods is also
something that we're quite intrigued
about and how that will have different
impacts on behavior and on physiology in
general and I really like this quote
from Hans le who's the father of stress
research he said that it's not stress
that kills us
but it's our reaction to it and so
really understanding the neurobiological
base of why if two people are on the
roller coaster of life and their
subjects is in the same stimuli that one
will be stress sensitive and the other
will be stressed acceptable and what are
the factors underlying this not just the
susceptibility but a lot of more
emphasis now is going on to
understanding stress resilience and we
know that genetics plays a role we're
getting a lot more information about the
epigenetic influences
but what if it's got to do with
something in your gut what if it's got
to do with the microbes within your gut
and I'll show you or over the next time
the information that we've gas that
helped us to come to that kind of
conclusion and where we hope that would
go overall and you know it's perhaps not
even you know we use the gut in our
everyday language all the time we have
phrases like gut feeling sort of gut
instincts we have butterflies in our
tummy to to personify our emotions and
so maybe what we're seeing is that our
emotions relevant to stress may be
gauged by what's going on
directly in Argos and we know that
stress as I mentioned impacts the entire
body and I just wanted to point out that
while it does have direct effects on key
circuits within the brain that we're
also fascinated about but in its impact
on the immune system and then therefore
on the immune systems bi-directional
communication with the brain
it's very important to understand stress
will also have effects directly locally
in the gastrointestinal tract and
changing lots of the physiology that's
going on in the gut and in particular
will have an impact on gut barrier
function and that barrier function is
important for maintaining an appropriate
immune response overall now I'm a
behavioral neuroscientist and so one of
the issues we have is trying to use
animal models to translate what we can
do in basic neuroscience into the clinic
and I like this cartoon in particular
from Gary Larson and not just because it
is an Irish Setter and in st. Patrick's
Day but it is it really encapsulate the
difficulties that we have in behavioral
pharmacology in trying to understand
what's going on and we can't just put
our mice or rats on a couch and ask it
ask them how their parents treated them
in their early life we require
behavioral assays that are robust
reliable and translatable to be able to
make that leap forward we also and so
there are of course distinct challenges
in this not least of all in terms of the
anatomy of the rodent brain and the
human brain where they're distinct
differences well we can and do use
rodents with a certain amount of
confidence when we're looking into
circuits that we know have been
evolutionary conserved via the reward
pathways in the brain or the fear and
anxiety circuits through the amygdala
and a number of years ago together with
my close colleagues Ted diamond and
Siobhan O'Malley in Cork we were
interested in
to see well what it happens and not just
in the brain but also across all
different systems in the body if we take
and rats and stretch them early in life
and we use the maternal separation model
that's been widely used by Polanski and
Michael Nene and many others and what we
found was that when rats were separated
from their moms for three hours a day
from postnatal day two to twelve when
they grew up they developed a wide scale
change across different system they had
increased abdominal pain they had an
exaggerated HPA axis response to stress
there have behavioral changes they had a
pro-inflammatory Siemens hock when we
looked at their guts there were changes
in permeability and in morphology in the
colon and so we're beginning to see that
really to reinforce the whole body
effects of stress a stress that happened
early in life and these are now adult
individual rats now what we did and
there was almost a looksie experiment at
the time because we had colleagues just
down the hallway who were able to help
us inland we also looked at the
composition of the microbes in the gut
the microbiome and what we found using
very crude techniques at the time was
that there was a shrinking of the
diversity of the microbiome in animals
that have been stressed early in life
that there was a signature of their
early life trauma that persisted into
adulthood and this was really intriguing
and got us thinking if stress can change
and then microbiome is there any other
way that we can understand this better
and more recently we've gone even back
further and looked at prenatal stress
stressing moms this is again in rats and
looking at the offspring microbiome in
adulthood and we find remarkably that
again there are persistent changes
microbiome and that we can correlate
these changes with changes in stress
related responses including changes in
cortical stearin and in the
physiological breathing response which
hasn't been shown before so long lasting
impacts of stress on the microbiome this
has recently been also shown in human
studies from Holland where they looked
at moms that had high perceived stress
during pregnancy and again the infants
when they looked at the infant's
microbiome later on they had a different
microbiome and they were able to
correlated with the stress in the mom so
again this field is slowly moving into a
more translational way and that were
being able to recapitulate some of the
effects we've seen in animals in human
and so it got us really exciting overall
that now we can see probably you know
for the first time you know that really
that stress is impacting the microbiome
and except you know in science and in
medicine there are very few new ideas
and so if we look back at older
literature from the 1970s there's very
nice paper from Jared Tanaka and doing
Savage which showed that stress might
show dramatic reductions in population
of lactobacillus
it wasn't taken up by the field there
was some subsequent work by Mike Bailey
and Chris Cole but very little work had
been done in that intervening 30 years
or so so we're now beginning to see that
stress affects the microbiome so why is
this microbiome and I guess that's why
many of you are tuned in today to hear
about the microbiome well we are living
in a microbial world and that's
important thing to say that when we look
at our genetic material we are 99
percent microbial if you think about the
amount of money we have invested as
taxpayers around the world in human
genes
and the Human Genome Project and that
accounts for less than 1% of what our
genetic makeup it's quite humbling in
general if I was giving this talk some
weeks ago I would have told you that we
were probably about 10 times more cells
that are microbial and human again
showing the field is moving fast and
with technology we're getting more and
more information and now that's been
revived in a paper in cell 2 that we're
about one point three to one microbial
we're still more microbial but just and
every day as we shed bacteria when we go
to the bathroom and perhaps we are just
becoming that little bit more human each
time and so that's an important factor
to to take into account the other one
that I want to reinforce is that the
weight of our microbes quickly about the
same as our brain again about 3 pounds
it's quite humbling as a neuroscientist
and also I need to tell you that we and
I'm guilty of this too often just think
about the microbiome of being bacteria
but also there's some really great data
coming out now in relation to viruses
the Byrom asian fungi etc so so we can't
neglect that and that we have co-evolved
with these microorganisms to become
what's known as the Newman Holub ions it
is perhaps one of the biggest areas and
all of me making the cover of all of the
Glamour magazine it's making the cover
of the science literature making the
cover of the New York Times The
Economist there must be money in it
creating a lot of innovation a lot of
startups coming in this field and it's
very exciting
overall I must say so where does our
microbiome come from where did we get
our microbiome well for the most part we
get our frontier bacteria from our mom
as we are being delivered into the world
through the birth canal so it's another
thing in psychiatry unfortunately we can
play my mother's fur and the it was long
thought that the an individual in the
room was maintained sterile but but now
we know that the placenta at least
harbors a unique microbiome and and this
has been also challenged evolutionary by
set board in China and others the
concept of but for the most part these
early bacteria that play a key role in
forming and our immune system and laying
down the colonization of because come as
from the birth canal and from the
environment and that is if we are born
by normal delivery or over a Terry W and
the third of the general population will
be born by c-section and if you're born
by c-section things are a little
different and work from glory Domingo's
bellows New York and others have shown
this quite dramatically that there is a
different microbiome present in infants
born by c-section compared to the
generally born and the health
consequences of that are slowly only
being resolved we know that if c-section
born infants are more likely to develop
allergy asthma and immune related
disorders but we're also now beginning
to think well what about its function in
relation to stress sensitivity or brain
health in general and studies are
ongoing to tease that apart if there is
any major effect and if there was I
think we would know it but about it by
now but it's also important in any from
a public health point of view in
countries where these are skyrocketing
c-section rates like Brazil are in
China and in southern Italy and you know
real regional differences in obstetric
practice that people just need to be
aware that there might be potential
health consequences of that and a lot of
effort is now going into trying to come
up with ways to be able to change the
normal c-section born infants microbiome
to be more like that of our pajama born
through different others who feeding
process are through dietary means
speaking of Dyess diet is another factor
which will really influence the
microbiome and we know that kids that
are fed which formula have a different
microbiome than those that are breastfed
this is often due to the prebiotics that
are present in breast milk that are
quite unique and important pre terms of
a different microbiome that than full
terms again and an important factor in
pediatric medicine genetics while I did
poo poo the role of genetics in medicine
pun intended a while ago we now know
that host genetics is very important
factor for heritability of microbial
factors and about 40% of the microbiome
is is heritable so that's an important
point as well and we're getting to know
more about that I mentioned already
about maternal stress but also maternal
infection and that's been studied often
in the context of neurodevelopmental
disorders where you live the environment
you live in will influence your
microbiome and the microbiome of the
built environment is becoming a really
hot area where architecture and and
design and engineering are interfacing
with microbiology to create an
environment where where we're exposed to
in different ways to different bacteria
and even this is now also coming into
the mental health literature work from
recent work from Chris Lowery's group
we're putting forward the concept of the
built environment and its importance for
mental health in relating it to the
microbiome around antibiotics are a key
factor that will also influence the
colonization early in life and have long
term potentially long term effects there
after a number of years ago my
colleagues at the APC microbiome
institute in Cork published its paper in
Nature which is really interesting
because what it does it looks at the
microbiome of the elderly so a lot of
the emphasis on microbiome research is
focused on early life well now this was
in the early early and they showed
following up almost 200 individuals that
their health outcome as they'd some of
them transition from living in the
community to into nursing homes etc
correlated very well with their
microbial diversity and the more diverse
their microbiome the more better their
frailty indices their immune function
and crude cognitive measures but that
wasn't the whole story and an
interesting one that it was but they
went one step further and looked at what
is driving the diversity of the
microbiome and what it was was what they
were eating and the diversity of the
diet will give a much more diverse
microbiome and while this is focusing on
the elderly and it's important and
demographic to be looking at in this
regard it also is important has
implications for all of us because
unlike our genome our microbiome is
modifiable to an extent and so diet is
an important factor there it also helped
to you know really contextualize when we
look at the elderly you know the brain
got access is very important to these
studies and as I said I'm interested in
stress and I'm particularly interested
what chronic stress does to the brain
but but but specifically in relation to
the elderly we know that there's an
inflammation process ongoing already and
that stressed will add fuel to that fire
and the way that the microbiome got
brain access is positioned and we
positioned it central in this pneumatic
here it allows it to be a very good
conduit for the negative effects of both
stress and aging but potentially through
diet or other means we could actually
tinker whether to reverse some of these
deleterious effects and have an impact
on cognitive impairment anxiety
geriatric depression as well as social
isolation which are all very important
factors in the elderly brain health
perspective
moreover science magazine before
Christmas had a whole special issue on
why we age and they also had a whole
section on the microbiome and aging from
my colleagues in Cork so it's becoming
now more accepted that when we're
looking at aging that we can also we can
be looking at the microbiome as a way
forward you know it's a whole new area
in biology and medicine that the
microbiome could help us deal with some
of the effects of aging and be the
secret aspects of aging and the diet is
important except it's not new at all
this guy elie metchnikoff won the Nobel
Prize in 1908 for his seminal immunology
work on phagocytosis and macropalous
was working in the Pasteur Institute in
Paris and Mexico later in his career
which is often the case he came up with
some what out there crazy idea that were
completely Chan genital to me to his
previous work where he was intrigued by
why people in certain parts of
in Europe live longer and he noticed and
put it down to the fact that the ace a
lot of fermented food and particularly
yogurts and and contained lots of black
PVC like and he's written about it in
the prolongation of life and this was
not really taken up by the mainstream
science or medicine at that time but
it's intriguing that we're beginning to
come around if you look at the what's
happening in the whole human genome area
right now this guy Craig bender is has
set up a commercial entity called human
longevity which is sequencing the human
genome of the elderly but he's they're
not doing that in isolation they're
looking at it in the context of the
human elderly microbiome and human
elderly the tableau and so perhaps you
know it's coming full circle in terms of
what Menshikov put forward and gives us
some insight we're interested in this a
lot ourselves and so this is some
unpublished data but I just wanted I
thought I would share with you where
we're going with this we've
characterized elderly mice and shown
that they have all of these behaviors
that I mentioned increased anxiety
cognitive dysfunction and we've been
looking at what could be driving aspects
of that and indeed when we look at their
Pro inflammatory phenotype they have an
exaggerated basal proinflammatory
phenotype and when we stress them it's
even further exaggerated but also we
began to start looking at the microbiome
in these elderly mice and again we do
find you won't be able to see all the
details it's mainly the concept that
changes in the microbiome could be
driving the changes in the inflammatory
phenotype which could be driving the
behavioural changes and so we're you
know this is something that we are quite
interested in and moving forward and
that the literature has become it's
becoming more and more exciting in this
there's a very exciting paper that's
been published online at the end of last
year and
current scenario showing that that
Alzheimer's disease pathology doesn't
emerge in animals that lack microbiome
and also in the immune system aging is
very important in this regard so so so
far I've talked about early life and the
microbiome and stress and aging and the
microbiome and stress and the other area
that we feel deserves attention is the
teenage brain and the teenage body in
this regard and looking at adolescent
brain vulnerability is very important
because it's an area where we can
actually tap into the impact of diet and
other changes that are going on and we
know that this is the time period when
certain disorders are right to emerge be
it substance use disorders schizophrenia
especially in males as well as certain
mood disorders and eating disorders so
and this is something that we feel
deserves a lot of more attention and so
we fed mice antibiotics throughout their
teenage years and weeks in this case
it's mice and we found that there was an
anxiety phenotype as well as a cognitive
Sina type that emerged and that this was
much more prominent in males than
females for reasons that we don't
understand but we are seeing these sex
differences time and time again and I'll
come back to that later so but all of
this really gets just thinking about
well what are they
factors that are Stig milling from the
microbiome to the brain and how are they
getting there and I think that's an
that's an important area which was only
hitting the tip of the iceberg we know
that that you know barrier function is
very important know that the bacteria
can signal student vagus nerve we know
that they have direct effects on the
immune system
and it's also worth noting the bacteria
our little factories for producing
metabolites be them neurotransmitters or
short chain fatty-acids for example and
here's just some examples work from Cork
it's been able to identify GABA
producing bacteria and bacteria that
modified the composition of fatty acids
in the brain work from Alain Charles
who's now at UCLA has really shown how
much a certain bacteria can influence
the synthesis of serotonin in the host
and marked lungs now in Iowa and really
put forward this whole concept that
bacteria are delivery vehicles for a
variety of neuro active compounds and
we're only scratching the surface of
what they may be I mentioned barrier
function because if your barrier becomes
some more leaky then it allows
infiltration of a variety of immune
cells and that can have direct effect on
the brain through stimulation by
bacteria or bacterial byproducts and
it's worth pointing out that the
microbiome is an important epigenetic
modifier and some of the metabolites
from bacteria and short chain
fatty-acids are probably the most
studied here can act as have direct
effects on histones and the histone
deacetylase inhibitors for example and
we put forward this concept a number of
years ago that really positions the
microbiome in a way to fulfill many of
the criteria of an epigenetic modifier
and of course with transgenerational
inheritance being so important of an
area in biological psychiatry today and
a lot of a long way to go to fully
understand it but bacteria perhaps one
of the best ways of vertical
transmission from mom to to offspring we
know that they will help microbiome or
help shape gene-by-environment
interactions and the
mentally regulated and it is potentially
reversible so fulfilling a lot of what
we will see so again this is work that
we're doing in Cork and we're very
excited about with Rome instilling a
postdoc in the group but it's we have a
long way to go to really tease it apart
so how do we study this that's one of
the questions how can you study this
microbiome to brain signaling what are
the methods well
inspection studies are laid the
groundwork along the way from the
classical cyclone your immunology days
moreover germ-free studies I'll talk
about this is bacteria without any
colonization in specific mice and
probiotic studies where you give a
specific strain that may have positive
attacks or antibiotic affects are also
very useful for delineating how
microbiota can influence the brain and
lastly fecal microbiota transplantation
taking someone else's poop and I will
come back to that before the end I
promise
so we fed animals antibiotics early in
life in a very nice study that she born
on Maui did and a couple of years ago
and what we found was that when these
animals grew up the good news for
parents and I have young kids who get
antibiotics is that there was no major
change in cognition anxiety distress
response or immune response but what we
did find was that there was a visceral
hypersensitivity and increase in
abdominal pain that was persisted into
adulthood and persisted across the
different antibiotic cocktails that we
were investigated and what's intriguing
here also is that if you look at the
microbiome of these individual rats at
the time when we look at their pain
responses the microbiome is no longer
different it had resolved but it tells
us that the microbiome being changed
early in life changed the wiring of some
of the pain pathways and then the
microbiome went back to normal but the
pain pathways didn't and
that is persistent it also may have
implications for infantile colic and
other abdominal changes but it's quite
intriguing and it's in line with the
theories put forward by Marty blazer in
NYU where he has really pioneered this
concept that exposure to low doses of
antibiotics early in life can have
long-lasting effects on metabolism in
general and that we as a society are
missing microbes that our ancestors had
that would protect us from developing
some of the Western disorders be it
obesity or multiple sclerosis or
inflammatory bowel disease for example
so again a lot of cultural work is being
going on between different parts of the
world you know looking at the microbiome
I'm showing it's much more diverse in
hunter-gatherers in Tanzania for example
compared to Western societies and so
that's something that we need to to
really understand from a public health
perspective germ-free animals I
mentioned and the idea of being
germ-free has you know taken our
attention for almost a century here is a
sci-fi magazine from the 1920s and you
have a germ-free man and then later in
life later on the advent of germ-free
mice and jaren prebiotic art and this
allowed us to have a really unique tool
that will enable us to answer a very
specific question and that's all they
can do is is the microbiome involved in
this process yes or no and the
development aspect too - yeah there's no
human cartlett perhaps only they may be
the boy in the bubble but these are they
mice in the bubble and growing up with a
bubble and this is a recent review we
have poliansky
put together trying to look at all the
information we have from germ-free
animals and while their clinical
translation is is important they have
allowed us to answer these very
fundamental
and I'll share with you now some of the
data that has and where's dollars and so
at the beginning of this talk I took you
on the journey that we had and showing
stress and early life impacted the
microbiome well there was also really
nice work from Japan from pseudos group
in Japan which showed that if you were
born germ-free if you didn't have
microbiome then you will have an
exaggerated HPA access to stress in
terms of the ACTH of course Cory Castro
and little bomb and intriguingly they
showed that they could reverse this by
putting in a single bacterial bifida
bacteria they could reverse this and
this paper is very important to the
field and I took a while for people to
really catch on to it and we really
appreciate the significance that I
really have and like it's often the case
in science when you come up with an idea
many other groups also have the same
idea and often published before you in
this regard and and this paper led
people to start thinking well the neural
circuits that are underlying the stress
response should also be different then
and really important paper from Michele
is hides this group and would spend
Patterson in Karolinska along with the
paper from Jane Foster and internal
noise field at McMaster and then later
our work all show the same thing in
principle that bacteria in the god
played a crucial role in mediating
stress responses anxiety related
behavior and gene networks that were
implicated in different complex
behaviors including anxiety here's some
of our data that Jerry Clark put
together which was to show that there
was a decrease in brain derived
neurotrophic factor in the hippocampus a
couple with an increase in serotonin and
so this really tells us you know that
the using germ-free animals that we can
really move forward and
and begin to interrogate this it also is
in line with really exciting work that
was emerging at the time from hammock
bird chicken Steve Collins's group in
McMaster looking at the impact of
antibiotics on BDNF levels in the brain
also more recently we also focused on
hippocampus but we started looking at
other factors and so we looked at an
adult hippocampal neurogenesis and we
know that we have continuously new
neurons being born in our brain and that
these are sensitive to being to negative
impacts of stress and inflammation and
aging and positive effects of learning
and physical exercise as well as
antidepressant drugs and what we found
was when we looked at what happens in
these germ-free animals we found that
they they they they they there is this
change in neurogenesis in these animals
and indeed there was increased
neurogenesis so the regulation of
neurogenesis the break is gone out of
kilter in these germ-free months more
recently we've turned away again this is
unpublished data but one that we're very
excited about - the amygdala and then
the amygdala we find that there's an
increased volume increase pine density
when we look at the hypertrophy there is
a change in the size and the morphology
of the amygdala and this is work that
Paulino sinski has been doing for now
some years in the lab to tease it apart
we've applied also a RNA seek approach
look at what genes are being changed and
they make that I would just published
that last year this is work from Roman
stealing and Hoban and others in the
group and really showing that there are
differential gene expression we took the
same approach to another brain area the
prefrontal cortex which is very
important for higher
decision-making and also for regulating
this fear and impulsive behavior and and
what we found was that when we when we
looked at what genes were being changed
in these germ-free mice we found that
there was a significant number of genes
relevant to myelin the insulation on
their selves and we validated this that
it was specific to the prefrontal cortex
all none of the other regions and this
is an area which we know the myelination
patterns is in this area sensitive work
from Mount Sinai has shown that that
that this area is particularly sensitive
to stress and chronic stress on
myelination and so here we get the
opposite a hyper myelination in terms of
up regulation of the genes involved and
when we looked at a.m. there was this
hyper myelination occurring so telling
us that fundamental processes in the
brain are regulated by the microbiome
other studies from other groups from San
Patterson's group has shown that the
blood-brain barrier for example is its
integrity is regulated by the microbiome
and that you could reverse this leaky
blood-brain barrier by providing
bacteria that secrete high amounts of
short chain fatty-acids that's quite
important as well very nice paper from
our co-princes group and in germany last
summer really changed a lot of how basic
neuroscientist start thinking about the
microbiome when they showed that the
activation state of the microglia
in the brain are under the control of
the microbiome and then if you looked at
germ-free or antibiotic treatment
animals but this changed and that there
elongation patterns was very change and
that they could reverse this by giving
short chain fatty-acids so very
intriguing because we know that
microglia are involved in so many
processes relevant to aging to synaptic
pruning and to neurodegenerative disease
and the neural inflammatory process and
now we have a way to regulate it through
the gut that's very intriguing it's also
you know didn't lose my note
that the microbial is very much
regulating something that is coming from
the work of Mexico Mexico discovered the
the macrophages and
microglia are the brains macrophages so
again reinforcing how right he was
I mentioned sex differences and we find
consistently in our germ-free animals
that a lot of the effects seem to be
more prone in and more robust in males
and females and so that led us to
looking at some of the behaviors are
relevant to male specific disorders
neurodevelopmental disorders like
schizophrenia or autism spectrum
disorders and so we took because we know
and that autism has four to one male
female race here and so what we want to
do is look at some of the core symptoms
about such as abnormal social
interactions and so we looked at these
germ-free mice and mice like humans if
you give them the chance to spend time
with an antechamber or another Mouse
would prefer to spend time with the
other Mouse but not if they lack
microbes mice like some humans are a
little bit fickle little preferred spend
time with a new playmate versus an old
one and again not if they're germ-free
they had increased repetitive behaviors
but also see in autism so it's telling
us that for normal social responses we
will need to have an appropriate
microbiome in our cause and it's quite
intriguing to in line with some of the
interesting data that's emerging in
animal models of to the clinically known
predisposing factors for autism which is
maternal infection or our maternal
exposure to by operate during pregnancy
and work from the Netherlands and from
Cal Tech from Sarkis mazmanian the late
Paul Patterson and Elaine Chao have
shown that there is changes in the
microbiome in these animal models and
which is led Jack Gilbert and Rob knives
to quite provocatively and perhaps
prematurely to put forward the car
that we could be developing down the
road probiotics for autism and other
neurodevelopmental disorders but this
led us to start thinking a little bit
about well you know why on Earth from an
evolutionary perspective would we
require bacteria in the lumen of our gut
- not normal social behavior and we
start constructing we now you know know
for a long time that elaboration of
course will function and brain maturity
or over throughout evolution has
responded to being in social groups and
that we know that the microbiome is now
playing a role in social behavior and so
we're beginning to close these loops and
together with Seth Borenstein in
Vanderbilt we started asking you know
could this play a role evolutionary in
our social responses and what Seth would
always say to me is always remember that
the bacteria were there first and that
we have co-evolved in our brain has
coped with these bacteria so this
reliance on bacteria has been very
important for our own brain development
and these bacteria and the microbiome
are our friends with social benefits so
we're beginning to develop a construct
where we can as neuroscientists we're
intrigued by what changes in the brain
occurs throughout our lifespan how that
may lead to the predisposition of
certain brain and disorders but now we
must jokes to close it with what's going
on in the microbiome at that point and
even in point earlier and that's going
to be very important and so we're
building a framework to be able to study
this quite well and as I mentioned that
stress especially in early life will
change the microbiome and that the mice
lacking the microbiome have exaggerated
stress response it leads us to start
thinking could be
delays the stress-related brain health
with the tinkering with the microbiome
it sounds true probiotics and in a study
that Javier Bravo did some years ago we
looked at whether if we said normal
healthy minds lactobacillus would they
have a will to change their behavior and
indeed it did they had reduced anxiety
reduced ante depression related behavior
in the for swim test their Court of
Gloucester in response to stress was
reduced and when we looked at their
brains there was wide scale changes in
gabon neurotransmission in their brains
which was quite started striking for us
but again the mechanisms for this needed
to be resolved and are quite important
to tease apart and I've shown you this
before this is sort of the communication
pathways and I did point out the vagus
nerve and together with John beanstalks
group and four sites at McMaster
University in Canada we performed sub
diaphragmatic vagotomy and cut off this
signaling pathway and lo and behold all
of the effects of this individual
bacteria were gone
so as I like to say this tells us that
what happens in Vegas will not just stay
in Vegas but affect our whole emotions
overall and while this is just one
pathway and not the only one it's very
important to try and delineate bago both
bi-directional beigel interactions and
mediating the gut brain responses and
that we need to be able to you know come
up with more rational ways of moving
forward with this into translating into
human and as well as some of the side
effects of certain drugs
so I mentioned fecal microbiota
transplantation the press lover did
something have that yuck factor and this
is basically taking someone else's fecal
material and meat being delivered as a
medicine and if you had cost radium
difficile seed if you definitely
try this if you were being resistant to
treatment and it saves countless lives
and because these people are
hospitalized and are slowly dying
because they're not responding to
conventional treatments but it has then
now people are investigating in an other
domain in Crohn's disease and metabolic
syndrome etc what about in psychiatry
and to my knowledge that no human
studies published out there yet but
there's this very intriguing paper from
Chapman poor chicken Steve Collins
McMaster where they looked at two
different mouse strains with two
different bacterial populations and
these mice differ in their anxiety
behavior and they did a transplant and
lo and behold they turned the resilient
NIH Swiss Mouse into about females and
vice versa and so this also has
implications if you move forward into
human trials that if you ever need to
get a transplant first seed if you
should make sure you have a very good
psychological profile of your donor at
the very least so all of what I told you
really is been coming out of animal
studies and we can criticize animal
studies could to have their limitations
of course but if they have really
enriched this field and been able for us
to move forward and for some reason
there's been very there's been
reluctance in clinical medicine to
actually take this and also industry has
had problems grappling with how to enter
in States because it's not a traditional
pharmaceutical approach to treating
brain health
but together but they would Ted diamond
and Katherine Stanton would came up with
this term psycho biotic which are
bacteria which were taken in how to quit
amounts will convey and positive mental
health and this is something that we are
now moving forward into human
translation and this is Andrew Allen a
postdoc in the group testing a specific
strain of bacteria that has emerged from
our animal studies that we've shown to
affect stress and cognitive performance
and animals and now we're moving it into
humans and doing EEG and other other
laboratory stress test and this is
proving to be really important and a
very exciting area and you know one that
we're very you know buoyed by and it's
really new really new except of course
it's not this is paper from the British
Journal of Psychiatry in 1910 on the
treatment of melancholia by lactic acid
bacteria so it's always good to be
remind of course brain imaging is going
to help as we move forward and there's
really nice paper from Ameren Meyer and
Carson Tillich in UCLA from a number of
years ago to show that a fermented milk
product containing four or so back
bacterial strains had direct effect on
emotional networks within the brain and
dampening down the response in an fMRI
so this is where the field is going and
we're slowly moving there towards more
psycho biotics and there are studies
emerging all the time they tend to be
small and then we need to need to really
move forward and have a larger scale
studies and we also need negative
studies because of course only a very
small fraction of the bacteria that are
out there gonna have positive effects
and we have to understand what is
causing these positive effects and where
they're going so told in conclusion I
kind of you know shared with you our
perspective and where the microbiome
influences the brain and I started
thinking of it
more and more like a puppeteer and and
puppet and and you can tell I have a son
who loves Pinocchio and then Pinocchio
had many adventures in his life but it
was sculpted by this puppeteer of
Geppetto and basically we were beginning
to see that the microbiome could be the
brain
Geppetto and helped to sculpt it in
early life and be always there when it
gets into a little bit of trouble along
the way and have a very important
relationship and we're beginning to
appreciate how this is through our
entire lifespan and that in the 20th
century our whole goal was killing
microbes
whereas now we realized how important in
microbiome is and that it reminds me a
little bit of TV shows like Downton
Abbey or Upstairs Downstairs where you
have two populations living in the same
house and they require each other for
survival but they go about ignoring each
other and it's only when something
happens downstairs that's a real trauma
occurs upstairs so I'll leave you with
this and your state of Gus will markedly
affect your state of mind I hope you
have a great st. Patrick's Day and this
is the work of a lot of people in Cork I
really point I went upon a diamond-like
very close clinical colleague who's head
of psychiatry and a whole host of many
other great people our funding agencies
and some of the industry partners that
we have and thank you for your attention
okay and now I'm ready thank you John
and a happy st. Patrick's Day to you -
we'll get right to the questions click
on the green Q&A button lower left and
submit your question you have a lot of
them today our first have you examined
the epigenetic link from stress to gut
microbes and changes in the micro RNA
messenger RNA balance it's a very
important question and we're very much
buoyed by the recent work that's showing
how there is a clear relationship
between the microbiome and host micro
RNAs as well so we have an ongoing
program tackling that right now but was
too early to have any definitive data
thanks John our next question does the
overuse of antibiotics and dairy and
beef farming affect the microbiome this
is really what Marty Blazers really what
Marty Blazers hypothesis is showing is
that it that that especially in the US
where there is a food chain exposure to
antibiotics more than other countries
that this could actually be
a very important aspect of this and
indeed but definitive proof is difficult
to get but but in his studies in his
rodent studies he proved that area
life's low dose penicillins can have
long-term effects a metabolic Al's
great our next question instead of
medication can we rely on a personalized
diet therapy to recover from a stressful
brain that's a that's a really good
question and one that it's almost too
early right now but a lot of people are
beginning to look at that and indeed
nutritional psychiatry is really growing
as an area people like felici Jaca in
Australia and others are really pushing
forward this concept that we might be
able to to diet and once we know more
about our personal microbiome and and
what diets could be used to actually
shape that and how that can change our
response to stress you could see
potentially how it could be used at
least as an adjunctive aspect to other
behavioral or pharmacological treatments
great our next question it's been
demonstrated that probiotics could
decrease anxiety and depression levels
what's your opinion about the use of
probiotics to modulate the pain in any
population with the microbiota
alteration okay so so we have to be
careful because a lot of the studies
with probiotics have not been subjected
to what rigor that we would be used of
in technical medicine so what is called
a probiotic a probiotic by definition
means some alive bacteria would have
proven health benefits and most of
what's available particularly in the US
haven't had that that rigor attached to
them so that's one of the problems with
with the probiotic field in general and
and a lot of the groups or scientific
groups are trying to really move
is forward and and that's why we like to
you know by pushing science behind we're
able to move forward but the point about
relation to pain is very important and
and we know that probiotics and
potential probiotics can modulate pain
pathways and in irritable bowel turn
there is probiotics that have had proven
one that was developed for my colleagues
in pork you know and pain is a key
pathway that's gone awry in irritable
bowel syndrome so I think it's a really
key area for testing in the future and
identifying what specific probiotics
would have beneficial in pain so okay
this is our last question that we do
have time for can gut bacteria secrete
factors that endogenous cells use as
part of their normal physiology ie short
or medium chain fatty acids did they
make a lot of yes they make a lot of
short chain fatty acids butyrate acetate
and propionate and they're used in all
aspects of host physiology of health and
are really one of the important
regulators of microbiome to brain
signaling potentially thank you so much
John we've had so many great questions
we're out of time for that but I just
like to throw it back to John time for
any final comments for our attendees
today thank you for your thank you for
your effort for tuning in live or on on
demand this is a growing field it's a
very exciting field it's good for
Neuroscience to think below the neck
sometimes and as you enjoy st. Patrick's
Day think about your microbiome and
think about ways to keep it well and all
thank you again John all the best to you
to today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through September of
2016 you'll be receiving an email from
lab roots alerting you as to when this
broadcast is available for replay we
invite you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thanks for logging on and
participating we hope to see you next
time goodbye